vraiment lieu de non
le parc du château de Maîche transporté
à l'époque de la Grande Guerre
l'association des poilus de la Marne y a
reconstitué un campement quatre tonnes
de matériel et d'objets d'époque ont été
acheminés pour l'occasion les bénévoles
ont maintenant la lourde tâches de
captiver les collégiens du secteur avec
des anecdotes qui font moche vous
connaissez tous la marque BN il va la
marque benne ça vient de la à la fin de
la guerre on avait fait tellement de
pain pour nos soldats qui restaient du
pain et du coup ben a décidé de mettre
de la confiture au milieu de mettre deux
biscottes et puis c'est comme ça que BN
a été créé avec des rations en
supplémentaires artillerie cuisine
infirmerie artisanat de tranchées
différents aspects de la vie au front
sont abordés 400 élèves sont attendus
avec leurs professeur de quoi rendre un
peu plus concret leur programme scolaire
c'est bien mieux d'apprendre ici qu'en
cours quoi être en face d'une feuille
avec un stylo
c'est un peu plus ennuyant que d'être
comme ça dans des conditions réelles
entre guillemets un événement organisé
par la Ville de Metz pour faire vivre le
souvenir des soldats de la guerre de 14
je suis rentrée dans l'association par
rapport à mon grand-père il me raconter
tellement de choses et puis je trouve
que c'est important de transmettre et de
montrer pour quand on en est là aux gens
comme aux enfants un devoir de mémoire
essentielle et plus que jamais
d'actualité il y a quand même eu selon
les différentes estimations disent voire
11 millions de morts pendant ce conflit
qui a touché le monde entier et
aujourd'hui depuis la fin des années
2000 2008 pour les Français il n'y a
plus de combattants de de cette période
donc il faut bien quelqu'un pour prendre
le relais et passer encore le message
puisque si on a la chance en tout cas ce
qui nous concerne de vivre en paix
depuis plus de 75 ans maintenant c'est
quand même grâce à la commémoration et à
la transmission de la mémoire et
notamment aux jeunes générations une
cérémonie de commémoration de
l'Armistice aura lieu avec les soldats
du régiment de Valdahon samedi et sera
ouvert au public en présence des acteurs